on va passer maintenant à une autre
forme de blague c'est le psy tuerie tu
perds c'est très simple on va faire
c'est top ça te plait chantal ne connais
pas mais je crois que c'était ce que tu
peux expliquer aux téléspectateurs
je dois être par exemple tiré de la
droite et brett hull ali g la nuit aux
partenaires qui est devant moi il aura
tout dans la bouder va m'aider à paris
exactement si naulleau sinon mamar aux
braves
[Applaudissements]
attention combien matin gad je vais te
demander de venir s'asseoir
tu va juste prendre de l'eau dans la
bouche et ensuite ce sera au tour de
chantal pour cette première battle
lequel des deux va rire d'abord sega
n'est pas une petite musique qui fait
peur ici vas-y ben voilà c'est moi qui
en raconte musique qui fait peur s'il
vous plaît marinara toi c'est toi et moi
et moi je fais quoi toi tu dois pas rien
attention attentes à 7 avec chantal ça
va être facile ce jeu mais tu veux pas
boire je dois garder l'eau dans la peau
comme ça dit quoi
oui voilà va en asie car de là mais il
boit toi gad elmaleh
j'aime beaucoup ce que du fait que des
pinocchio quand il pète devant tout le
monde
désolé geppetto prévu ça je m'attendais
pas à ça à toi tu à paris tout à paris
non non parce que je n'en ai pas marre
chantal rouleau
non mais c'est fou ce truc kyoshin car
j'ai une carte faut espérer avoir une
mauvaise vanne en face et ça non une
brève mais est-ce que si tu les laisses
que si tu es raconte mal ça veut dire
que tu ne comprends pas non pas
forcément
chantal on dirait jean pierre foucault
vous qu'est ce qu'un chameau à trois
boss ne répond pas c'est nous c'est un
chameau qui s'est cognée stade bachir et
attention on me dit tu sais mon cher
face à gap tu peux prendre à d'autres je
tenais je tenais à notre ère j'te manet
reprend vas-y qui dit la blague vois ça
tu vas dire là bas moi j'ai dit la ville
es tu adores cent au cours du pétrole
étaient super bowl
oui non mais t'as bu l'eau mais non non
alors qu'est ce qu'un casque un oiseau
qui se grattent que d'un côté je me
tiens
l'oiseau migrateur
[Applaudissements]
tu restes tu y es tu es ici si tu es
qualité assez cool de gagner ma merde
attention philippe jamet alors qu'ils
fla c'est toujours toi c'est toujours
moi toujours la frbtp et okc ce n'était
pas présent mauvaise vanne prend une
mauvaise vague n'est pas du jus d'orange
j'ai rien dit alors quel super héros
donne le plus vite leur c'est spider man
c'est bon c'est bon j'ai pas vérifié du
bois à toi philippe tu peux prendre une
banque pourrie mais c'est ça le but on
fait je crois
que diane hognon kanté en france alors
que di antonio tandis que gianni le
diane audio que discute
aïe ça passe à toi attention mais
j'aurais cela a bien sûr n'est pas droit
de vous protéger
alors quel est le quel est leur pape
préféré de dracula
le croque le croque-monsieur partie des
lots spécifiques et tenant du titre ne
m'en fais je m'attends donc à la bouche
c'est déjà un peu galerie mais c'est ça
le truc déjà même la question de la peau
mais je savais pas plus la question
comme foucault onuci presse a vraiment
fait une phase ya là ça va être très dur
de six mois c'est toi c'est toi c'est
lui qui raconte c'est lui le tenant du
titre était à les charger une bonne
bouche ou [ __ ] alors attention
qu'est ce qui n'est pas un steak une
pastèque
il a tenu bon
en fait tu peux retrouver et quel est le
comble pour un plombier que ses clients
prennent la fuite
ça passe ça passe un petit fille j'ai eu
de la chance n'était pas la plus
d'enfants ça il ajoute alors bonjour
plus en prendre plus mais tant que le
dira c'est quoi un pépito le soir
[Rires]
j'avais trop d'où je suis je suis un nom
de la folie d'après ce que je disais ce
jeu c'est nul parce qu'une tu gagnes et
tu te prends de la fleur à la main se
passe gonflé japon s'était joué six
trith hugon futur mari dans leur terre
battue va nous faire surprendre la
caravane à travers mon sac
alors que fait une fraise sur un cheval
le fn ferait sur un cheval s'est perdu
mon petit frère pour le faire rire plus
beau c'est bien qu'ils commencent par
ckoi moi je bois oui tu as tu racontes
tu raconte celui qui boit vazimba c'est
lui qui arrive ne vois bien oui il aime
bien mettre à houla ah oui
qu est ce qu un canif qu est ce qu un
canif un petit fiant un petit chien un
petit chien position
évidemment c'est unique les vannes je
suis désolé quoi un petit fils adoptif
maintenant finir à dix à dix mois c'est
ça toi
et oui tu prends à côté nationaux vous à
cannes un film où ils se cachent mozart
dans le frigo parce que mozart l heure
[Rires]
alors tu veux que tu vaux qui donne
aussi at il dit si tu veux garde il veut
garder attend sa chance à ce jeu le kiné
si le participe passé au travail c'est
un moment magique là tu vois que disent
les maîtres nageurs au nouvel an à qui
bon à phnom penh et y aura un
commentateur de danse et jeux baduel
rappelons et qui participe pour la
troisième année le championnat
international il arrive en demi finale à
las vegas docteur vous pensez que je
suis nymphomane dès que vous me lâcher
la beach vous répond laurent baffie qui
retrouve ici un style bien à lui
[Applaudissements]
je sais pas moi c'est faux tu te
ségatier bois noranda ramener ta propre
bouteille d'el maleh on assiste là un
match au sommet les deux ont fait leurs
preuves à différents endroits
laurent baffie chez thierry ardisson
pendant des années maintenant chez cyril
hanouna et gad elmaleh dany jana
alé lô que fait une mouette qui
partagent un gâteau elle fait
[Rires]
à toi gal ba oui tu permanent auquel
mais vous la six personnes qui disent à
vannes bon alors mais c'est si c'est
vachement oppressant que font deux
brosses à dents non meurette mais non
mais non mais non mr est non c'est robin
non mais c'est vrai qu'ils respectent
pas les règles ma fille il ya la
distance de sécurité est bien que font
deux brosses à dents le 14 juillet pays
mme stress parce que c'est pas clair ce
qu'il veut en fait il a une grande force
de maîtrise que font deux brosses à
dents le 14 juillet et une autre tête un
feu dentifrice téléphone il est très
fort tu penses que tu peux pas y fait
rire gagnent déjà parce que toi je veux
que tu perdes oit est-ce que tu ne ris
pas tu penses que tu peux faire ma fille
guérit pas de date en garde me fait
énormément rire ah ouais ben pas là bas
ça se voit je suis très fan de gala je
sais oui
vas-y vas-y à toi donc bien les joueurs
beat couilles qu demi [ __ ] enculage
[ __ ] à tort y coule tu peux donné en q
les [ __ ] à tort vide couilles qu
sodomie [ __ ] entre attente ardisson
ardisson à 10 ans à 10 heures
des fouilles couillard dissaux les
couilles agissons de ses beats oui moïse
a conçu les [ __ ] adore beach boys
calculator bits
[Applaudissements]